starwars eight might have just been
delayed but don't think that I'll spare
you from extensive exhaustive Star Wars
coverage my friends today I'm covering a
star wars game that never even existed
I'm Kate and this is your gamespot news
update new gameplay footage that
apparently stems from a playable
prototype version of the cancelled star
wars battlefront 3 emerged this week
providing a new look at the ill-fated
game posted on reddit by a person who
says they aren't a big star Wars fan but
does take interest in prototype games
the footage showcases a somewhat rough
version of the much-discussed game that
was in development at free radical
design the UK studio that was eventually
folded into Crytek according to the
reddit user whose name is proto [ __ ]
who says I want to apologize my name as
it was the name given to me from 4chan
to ensure they know who I am when I post
this a build of the game is playable on
xbox 360 development kits a link to the
game build was removed by reddit mods on
the basis that it apparently constituted
pirated copyright material however
videos from the battlefront 3 prototype
have popped up online showcasing combat
on Hoth I hope you all have a nice time
with this proto [ __ ] said after a lot
of work I managed to get my hands on
star wars battlefront 3 and wanted to
share the infamous cancelled game that
I'm sure many of you wanted to play do
you think we missed out on this game or
does the recent Star Wars Battlefront
scratch that itch let me know in the
comments or come find me on Twitter how
not to draw thanks for watching and for
all your games entertainment and endless
star wars updates keep it gamespot
you